foreign New York City is now finally
feeling the full effect of Joe Biden's
border crisis as New York city mayor
Eric Adams announced that the illegal
immigrants in his City they would be
relocated to the Brooklyn Cruise
terminal from their hotel and Hell's
Kitchen by the way this decision
prompted a massive backlash from illegal
immigrants who have now set up tents
outside the hotel to protest their move
now tonight Joe Biden is in New York
City he's touting all of his
infrastructure spending by the way in
case your county we have 31 trillion
dollars in debt that you're passing on
to your kids and grandkids not that many
people in Washington seem to care but as
usual Joe refused to address illegal
immigration that he caused over 5
million illegal immigrants got into this
country because of his policies that
aided and abetted that activity now this
once again begs the question why is Joe
refusing to see what his open borders
crisis is doing to the country or very
on giano Caldwell he spoke to New
Yorkers outside of the Watson hotel
where the migrants set up camp and
here's what they had to say take a look
so President Biden was here today he
didn't come and see the migrants what do
you think
um it would be nice if he'd come down
but I'm sure he's very busy he has no
plans of coming down here to talk to the
migrants what do you think
well me everybody should see you we
already know that he don't I mean he
don't care about anything about anything
it's like a classic thing so he don't
care about nothing that's going on with
these people down here you know what I
mean the fact that a president who ran
on this kind of a platform that's you
know promises are going to work at
fixing and resolving some of these
matters the fact that he would be here
and ignore it is a little telling
you think President Biden has failed on
the immigration issue absolutely 100 and
and for years
all right channel now joins us live
outside the hotel with more reaction so
their position is we don't care we like
the hotel we were living in and we're
not going to move to the other place is
that it
yeah it appears to be the case on that
some of these migrants are taking a
stand to Simply say we have no interest
in moving to another facility this is
where we want to be and as I spoke to
some of the residents I got the sense
from them that there is a caring
consideration about the well-being of
the migrants but some wondered why
should they have to capitulate to
fitting the bill fitting a bill when
they have their own Financial
considerations that they're not
receiving help from the city on I get
the sense Sean that this is going to be
an issue that mayor Adams is going to
have to deal with for some time
especially if President Joe Biden is
refusing to come and see what the
results of his border policies are and
this isn't something that he's going to
be able to uh kick under the rug if you
will
all right General thank you so much for
that report we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else